what can Insight can you give us on the
inside as to what ukrainians think about
their leadership as to what Russians
you're saying about Putin and maybe the
stories that we're just not hearing in
the news
definitely deserves a Academy Award for
being the greatest [ __ ] hardest on
the planet I mean the way he can just
spin everything and just deny everything
he's done and you know like listen I
we're we're rebuilding like half of
bucho right now with all those things
you know happen and all those massacres
happen I've personally met everybody in
bucha you know I asked them for example
you know who did this to you who killed
your wife who killed your children you
know it was all Russians but the Putin's
able to twist that and say that it was
staged by Americans that the ukrainians
did this to make them look bad right so
this is a master master manipulator
manipulator right and since he controls
the KGB I mean this is kind of in his
blood right he controls stage
to a point where every single Russian
girl that I know can't see my posts on
Instagram about what I'm doing in
Ukraine I mean they have no idea what's
going on they just see what they want
them to see so it's easy to brainwash a
whole population if you don't give them
access right to the truth
so you know it's it's a lot of confusing
messages zielinski on the other hand
had he not been an actor it's a lot of
similarities actually in in the journey
if you think about where I went through
right had I not been
a nightlife you can always trust in
God's like master plan for your destiny
right had I not been a nightlife guy for
20 years everyone's like what's a
nightlife guy doing what you're doing
now yeah there's no chance I'd be able
to do what I'd be doing and had I not
been a builder it's like The Nightlife
taught you the ability to like Network
and right yeah come to the club tonight
right how about now go to the
hospitality making people feel welcome
and warm that's that's in your DNA how
about coming to the warehouse and
volunteer to help Puerto Rico right now
that's the same exact job right how
about instead of hey you want to come
buy a 10 000 bottle for Tiësto why not
donate ten thousand dollars to help
people right
yeah it's really a similar thing the the
logistics scheduling hundreds of trucks
and planes and containers and everything
yeah to do a decade of running
construction jobs right that I was doing
before as a as a developer and having
Crews of 200 people whether they're you
know hammering something or whether the
loading pallets it's all like a part of
management so that skill set that I
learned to be able to execute what I do
today
is the exact same analogy then
zielinski had zelinski not been a
comedian an actor and Starstruck and all
of that he wouldn't have the ability to
go on TV and literally like every minute
say look what this guy's doing to us you
have to stop him I need weapons if you
don't give me the weapons to stop him
he's going to take cave then he's gonna
take Poland then he's going to take
Finland he'll never stop
so that's what he's basically saying
about Putin
and and honestly it's the truth yeah
I assure you if if if Putin would have
got Keith if they would have made it
past Butcher and he would have got he
doesn't just stop we live in a very
different world right now we live in a
very different world yeah they were not
taken so you're saying the USS yeah
you're giving Putin the uh Academy Award
for acting like he's not doing evil
things whereas zelinsky deserves credit
for uh his background as an actor
comedian to kind of uh Galvanize the
world in his uh favor uh to his side for
you know to win the war in Russia that's
kind of the analogy that you're using
right there imagine I live in key right
now no you guys see on the news a you
know missile that hits a shopping mall I
literally Drive in our car with our
teams the next day and we're speaking
and seeing it and the fire is still like
smoking and I'm watching this with my
own eyes and then you have Putin going
wasn't us
yeah it's the ukrainians that did this
to themselves I mean it's beyond like an
Academy Award it's just of course and
and it's unimaginable to think and
that's why America is great with this
you know
uh freedom of speech there is no freedom
of speech there what they see in Russia
right now is a completely different
story yeah and it's this you know you
were talking about you know people
getting arrested I mean look look what's
happening look look at our freedoms we
have Russia yesterday announced that
they were going to basically do a draft
now because they're losing the war right
and they're just gonna basically take
300 000 people you're going to you know
kill some ukrainians now for the because
they're Nazis right even though the
president's Jewish come on yeah and
that's a good one and they Rebel right
there's a little movement in Moscow and
right and
and what what did you hear what just
happened they arrested like 1200 people
they immediately drafted them
did they arrest the actual people
because I heard there was a lot of
mothers basically saying I don't want my
kids to go to war that they were the
ones revolting and then they're the ones
kind of feeling the Wrath of the uh
Russian police so in America if you
don't like something you go out with a
sign and you yell in the worst case
scenario you know they're gonna like
push you back or something over there
you hold aside and say you're against
the war you're immediately arrested and
now you're gonna go fight in the war wow
they're gonna basically just put you in
the front line to get you killed so if
you like that clip click right here to
watch another or if you want to watch
the entire saucecast click right here
thank you